hello everyone it's Justine back in my
kitchen and I've got some stickers today
because we are about to hop into Saint
Patrick's Day festivities we're gonna
start baking a st. Patrick's Day
something here but I was like man I
really wish that I had a green t-shirt
and I only have one and that one I'm
going to wear for st. Patrick's Day I
gotta save it well I do have it some
stickers so I've got a pot of gold here
on the microwave but I've got this
little I think I'm just gonna put it
here
yeah that's it no it's happy to bacon
not even baking actually if you read the
title this video it's green eggs and not
him and that not him is green pancakes
let's get all of our ingredients ready
we're gonna need not very much actually
at all we're basically making pancakes
and all you need is water for the
pancake mix and for the green eggs you
need eggs and green food coloring whoa
this is just loose 2 cups of dry mix so
let's do that
and you go one and a half cups of water
now I'm gonna add some green food
coloring this is basically the theme of
all the st. Patrick's Day videos is
green food coloring definitely not good
for your health
never once did I ever claim that
anything their name
do not beat or overmix am i beating it
beat it so I'm doing exactly what you're
not supposed to do
to be fair I read the box while I was
doing the thing that I'm not supposed to
do so just let me let me live Cobb this
shirt is disgusting like it's wrinkled I
really like to look like this yeah like
I could I put on different shirt like
this is it actually is disgusting but
whatever this is the life that I'm
weeding this is getting warm very
quickly let's find some butter to get it
all juiced up Wow let's talk about
sizzling
[Music]
did I just make a pancake
yes so this is definitely time to flip
oh shoot Oh God oh jeez
Oh gah oh boy oh boy I should probably
start making another ones I've got this
whole freaking thing
Oh Oh No oh my god
no I'm shook it okay I'll put that in
the hole there's a hole you shove the
butter into these look don't look like
circles my hair's getting stuck in my
sticker
happy early st. Patrick's say welcome to
my restaurant day featuring yeah I'll
just finish up this mix
this is boring I'm making pancakes and
they look disgusting see talent when
someone says Justine why do you do for
fun what are your talent this is the tip
I will say look at my talents
did you see that I could do this all day
like honestly let's just put this big
guy oh he is he is a beefy beefy boy
okay so now what we're gonna do is we're
basically going to making the egg whites
green and then I'm gonna hopefully save
the yolk I put that in the middle so
it's gonna in theory work but as we know
about my theories yeah they don't go so
well okay save him and put him in here
Oh
oh that's a lot that's a lot by a little
anyway a Sol green
we're gonna put the green in and help
this works I think I beat it too much so
I wanted to put the egg in the middle
see look because it needs a cook from
the top man this is actually turning out
so good and it's almost done cooking and
I'm gonna keep this on for a little bit
longer until it's completely cooked at
the top
[Music]
so because it took me so long to make
this egg I had to put the pancakes back
on the griddle so that they would get a
little bit warm so I also have something
that I made ahead of time which is very
exciting these are gold coins I melted
butter and I put these little gold
flecks in them before I put the melted
butter in I dusted this gold powder on
the inside of this so I don't even know
what this is gonna look like but we're
gonna find out because this is this is a
group effort here so let's take a peek
of our gold butter medallion I mean I've
seen worse it's not bad you can actually
see this a little bit of a little bit of
butter gold on there I'll come up closer
so let's see if it melts all right
pancakes you look delicious well guys
thanks for watching these are our
pancakes and our green egg green egg and
not ham the not ham is pancakes you know
I really think that I should reconsider
cooking videos because every time
something as simple as a pancake how
could I mess it up I don't know it is a
truly an art form
I feel like to be able to be this bad at
cooking thank you guys for watching look
for another fun st. Patrick's a video on
actual st. Patrick's Day which is March
17th in case you didn't know Alexa told
me um bye no I'm not eating this because
I do not want to die I think I'm crazy
[Music]
you